foreign
[Music]
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me
Annihilation by Jeff Vandermeer is one
of my favorite science fiction books to
come out in the last 10 years it's no
secret that I'm a big fan of
lovecraftian horror and this particular
book is one of the best modern examples
that I can locate now you might have
seen the 2018 adaptation of This Book of
the same title it's a fantastic movie
but different in a lot of ways from the
book the book is much more cerebral and
less action driven the strangeness and
the wildness of the environment produces
a sense of uneasiness and mystery and
dread the book follows an expedition of
four people as they enter area x a
secretive government organization has
gathered them up to explore the
mysterious area and keep journals on
everything that they encounter but the
world they enter once they cross the
border into area X is one almost
impossible to describe now I have to
stop here to say
you have not read this book you might
want to stop to avoid spoilers even if
you've seen the movie because there are
some pretty significant differences
a key fact about this book is that the
members of the Expedition team other
than the psychologist are told almost
nothing about what area X is or even
exactly what they're doing there we
learn in the book that over the course
of 18 months the last Expedition team
disappeared one by one from area X and
reappeared with their families only they
were different changed somehow something
about them was uncanny they were
themselves but not themselves they all
died of cancer within six months it is
never revealed how they left area X
it is also revealed that several of the
earlier Expeditions either committed
suicide or killed each other a curious
thing about the current Expedition which
is supposedly Expedition number 12 is
that they are given archaic technology
nothing that represents the current
state of human technological progress
they are given old guns old cameras
nothing from the present they are also
given some kind of measuring device when
it glows red they were to remove
themselves to a safe place but they were
not told what they were hiding from or
what the measurement warned against or
exactly what the device measured they
were also forbidden watches and
Compasses the major part of what drives
this book is trying to figure out how
much can we actually trust the
government organization that sent them
on this Expedition and this is
intensified when we realize the role in
which hypnotism plays in this story now
this is an aspect of the book that's
mostly missing from the movie the leader
of this Expedition is a psychologist the
psychologist has certain commands and
Trigger Words which allow her to control
the others in the group at one point in
the story due to an infection from
strange spores the protagonist the
biologist becomes immune to the hypnosis
over the course of the book she wonders
how much of what they were told about
area X was even true to begin with
perhaps their entire conception of what
it was what little conception they had
was totally inaccurate to start with
no one had as yet plumbed the depths of
intent or purpose in a way that had
obstructed that intent or purpose
everyone had died or been killed return
changed or returned unchanged but area X
had continued on as it always had while
our superiors seemed to fear any radical
reimagining of the situation so much
that they had continued to send in
knowledge strapped Expeditions as if
this was the only option
feed area X but do not antagonize it and
perhaps someone will through luck or
mere repetition Hit Upon some
explanation some solution before the
world becomes area X
and chilling fact about area X is that
this had been a place where people once
lived but even before this area along
the coast became known as area X it had
not been a normal place
even years before the so-called border
appeared there had been a Proto area X
by the end of the novel the protagonist
discovers that going back years there
had been remissions followed by
flare-ups and horrible manifestations
the ebbing and flowing of strange life
pulsing breathing in and out in and out
until it finally bloomed into area X and
started expanding outward the horror and
the Mystery is greatly expanded when we
discover that the government has sent
way more than 12 Expeditions the
Expeditions possibly go back decades
The Entity if you can call it that that
is causing all of this is named by the
biologist in the book The crawler
the crawler is some kind of being
that lives in what the book calls the
tower but it's not really a tower it's
more like a tunnel that goes straight
down into the Earth
the walls of the tunnel itself are live
somehow and forming upon the walls are
various strange words
but whether it decays under the Earth or
above on Green Fields or out to sea or
in the very air all shall come to
Revelation and to Revel and the
knowledge of the Strangling fruit and
the Hand of The Sinner shall rejoice for
there is no sin in Shadow or in light
that the seeds of the Dead cannot
forgive
there shall be a fire that knows your
name and in the presence of the
Strangling fruit its dark flame shall
acquire every part of you
for whatever reason the creature changes
everything around it it takes DNA and
mixes it we discover that the moss on
the ground has human DNA we see dolphins
with human eyes
this thing whatever it is is remaking
the world as it sees fit it is taking
the world from us and creating it Anew
and the environment that it's producing
is pristine perhaps horrific confusing
or incomprehensible to us perhaps
inhabitable to us as humans but the
ecosystem that lives there thrives the
author is definitely making a statement
about how we treat the Earth how we
abuse its resources and here comes this
life form giving the planet Back To
Nature not nature as we know it a new
nature but how can we say that what it's
doing is bad compared to what we've done
to the planet we don't know exactly
where this creature came from but we do
know that it manifested
initially near the lighthouse on the
coast we know this because the
Lighthouse Keeper was the first human
that it encountered and it kept the
Lighthouse Keeper with it and horror and
Agony and ecstasy forever trapped within
the crawler the last Lighthouse Keeper
stared out at me so it seemed not just
across a vast unabrigible Gulf but also
out across the years for though thinner
his eyes receded in their orbits his
jawline's more pronounced the Lighthouse
Keeper had not aged a day since that
photograph was taken more than 30 years
ago
this man who now existed in a place none
of us could comprehend did he know what
he had become or had he gone mad long
ago
could he really even see me
the creature had taken the Lighthouse
Keeper merged with him somehow keeping
him alive in terrible stasis it is not
at all clear why it did this the
motivations of the creature seem unclear
even random at face value
but they aren't it is intelligent though
it may be incomprehensible to the human
mind
some of the crawler's motivation can be
deciphered from the writings that it
left on the wall for instance I shall
bring forth the seeds of the Dead this
is a reference to the crawler creating
doppelgangers of the Dead members of the
Expedition team and a reference to human
DNA being mixed into the ecosystem
literally seeds of the Dead another
example is there shall be a fire that
knows your name and in the presence of
the Strangling fruit its dark flame
shall acquire every part of you this is
a reference to how the crawler acquires
information we see this at the end of
the book when the crawler with its
incomprehensible flame reaches into the
body of the biologists to gather all of
her DNA and all of her thoughts and copy
them so maybe the crawler is a traveler
From Another Dimension or from outer
space maybe it's a scientist and it's
doing experiments maybe the changes to
our environment aren't necessary for it
to live it is just simply
testing
reactions
and measuring the change of the
environment not really considering that
this is affecting the current ecosystem
or that it's affecting Humanity
it could also be potentially true that
the crawler is intentionally trying to
save the Earth from Humanity by changing
everything and remaking it anew and the
flip side of that it could be that the
crawler is a malevolent entity
now I tend to think that the first
option is the most true I think the
crawler is a traveler and Explorer I
think the changes that it is causing to
our environment is either a byproduct of
its natural existence that has nothing
to do with any intent or will on its own
part or it's consciously manipulating
the environment to suit itself it could
also be that the crawler is an agent or
manifestation of the will of some other
being or entity
it's also mentioned in the series that
area X is expanding faster and faster it
will continue to expand and there seems
to be nothing they can do about it and
they still have no idea what the crawler
is or where it came from
perhaps he had seen it
coming from Atop The Lighthouse
the event arriving like a kind of wave
and what had manifested
what do I believe
think of it as a thorn perhaps a long
thick Thorn so large it's buried deep in
the side of the world
injecting itself into the world
emanating from this giant Thorn is an
endless perhaps automatic need to
assimilate and to mimic a simulator and
assimilate it interact through the
Catalyst of a script of Words which
Powers the engine of transformation
Perhaps it is a creature living in
perfect symbiosis with a host of other
creatures
Perhaps it is merely a machine
but in either instance if it has
Intelligence that intelligence is far
different from our own it creates out of
our ecosystem a new world whose
processes and aims are utterly alien
one that works through Supreme acts of
mirroring and by remaining hidden in so
many other ways all without surrendering
the foundations of its otherness
and it becomes what it encounters
Annihilation is one of my favorite
modern lovecraftian style science
fiction horror books so if you're
interested in that sort of thing
definitely check this book out have you
read it already what did you think also
have you read the other books in the
series I haven't yet but I plan on doing
so soon I might cover them on the
channel in the future thanks for
watching guys peace out
between demonetization and just the
unstable nature of AD revenue on YouTube
and due to constant rule changes and
increased censorship YouTube isn't the
best place for Content creators if you
want to support the channel and make
sure we stay afloat consider checking
out our patreon we've got all new perks
including access to a patreon only
channel on Discord Early Access to
videos and a once a month Patron only
live stream also 10 and up patrons get a
copy of the ebook and the audiobook
version of my graphic novel tadia we've
got other perks like your name appearing
in videos and also special roles in the
Discord server and more perks to come
check it out thanks guys
just a heads up for those of you that
may be interested my next graphic novel
the LIE behind the star is launching
February 2023 you can sign up now to get
on the email mailing list to get
notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]